58e festival d'avignon intéressant nous
offre ce soir avec les représentations
données à la chapelle du verbe incarné
où se produisent depuis plusieurs années
des troupes de l'outre-mer cette fois
les femmes ont pris le pouvoir dominique
poncet nathalie berthier
venus des quatre coins dautremer et même
d'un peu ailleurs elles sont enceintes
et avignon et dans les rues elles
chantent leur bonheur de pouvoir faire
enfin entendre leur voix dans ce qui est
le plus grand festival de théâtre du
monde
théâtre chant danse elles vont emprunter
tous les chemins artistiques pour dire
leur colère leur souffrance leur joie et
aussi leur incroyable faculté de
résistance
son visage recouvert explicatifs ont dû
à des coups de rasoir au coin les femmes
peut être aussi parce que les femmes
portent beaucoup la culture et qui
exprime aussi beaucoup ce que les hommes
dans la société ne pouvait pas trop
exprimé n'y a pas de faux semblants chez
nous c'est à dire qu'on sent les choses
on les dit comme elles sont ça peut
choquer les gens à blaise parfois mais
c'est comme ça comme ça c'est à dire
qu'en jouant sur le plateau nous jouons
aussi une autre réalité
qui de respect il m'a poussé contre le
mur et may cry en pleine figure une
réalité parfois très instituée par les
macoutes
parfois aussi très singulière comme
celle de thérèse
84 ans
alors voilà tout
j'étais
un enfant et une idée je suis devenue
une jeune fille je ne savais pas si
j'étais pauvre si j'étais riche
et j'étais naturel et quand je suis
arrivé en france j'ai vu autre chose il
a ouvert le petit porte-monnaie et il
m'a donné
trois
c'était beau femme d'andré femmes
passion fann résidence des pins avignon
elle mène leur voix et les entendre est
à la fois beau et bouleversant
ok